We Begin this hour with a highly
anticipated new movie and the true story
behind it
Jesse break left
Happy Hunting it's bow time
whoa devotion which stars Jonathan
majors and Glenn Powell hit theaters
this week it tells the inspirational
story of two Navy pilots who fought in
the Korean war which began in 1950 when
North Korea invaded the South jarika
Duncan has been following their story
for more than seven years she spoke with
the actors and reflected on her
conversation with one of the heroes
whose story they tell
the movie devotion based on a true story
travels back in time to the Korean War
it follows the lives of Two fighter
pilots Tom hudner and Jesse Brown played
by actors Jonathan majors and Glenn
Powell this movie meant so much to so
many people I've never seen a crew rally
around a story like I've seen this one
and high everyone wanted to get it right
Jesse Brown being the first
African-American Naval aviator I went oh
it's not done that before I've not told
the story of the first anything this is
not the Buddy film this is a film about
fate and Legacy devotion was first a
book released in 2015. that same year I
interviewed the real Tom hudner at age
90 he described his memories of Jesse
Brown
were a very positive personality and was
a friend to everybody
the son of a sharecropper Brown grew up
picking cotton in Hattiesburg
Mississippi you were out here before the
sun came up his brother Fletcher took us
back to the field where the seeds to
Jesse's pilot dreams were planted what
was Jesse's reaction when those planes
would get so close to you I would be
talking about he's going to do that
yeah that's what he's gonna do
hudner had a far different experience he
grew up in Massachusetts joined the
Naval Academy and says he became a pilot
at the urging of his friends
but it's what happened on One mission in
1950 that bonded these two men Forever
After Brown's plane was shot down in
North Korea hudner intentionally
crash-landed his to try to save his
friend I couldn't move
why not
he he was pinned in the first thing he
said was Tom we've got to figure out a
way to get out of here in the end there
was nothing hudner could do I couldn't
think of anything worse
than watching death approaching sitting
in that airplane
and not being able to get away from it
what did Jesse tell you to tell his wife
before he died yes he wanted his wife to
know how much he loved her and that was
the message I gave to her Brown's wife
Daisy would later stand by hudner's side
President Harry Truman who signed an
executive order ending racial
segregation in the U.S armed forces
awarded hudner with the Congressional
Medal of Honor for his efforts to save
Brown
in October hudner and brown were honored
at the Naval Aviation Museum in
Pensacola Florida the families reunited
including hudner's son and Brown's
granddaughter who talked about the movie
we've always known that this was a
really amazing story and exciting that
the world now gets to know of it I think
having a platform of a major motion
picture really elevates it so that more
and more people we'll get to know the
story of Jesse and Tom I figured that
this would be the closest that I would
get to experience what my dad and what
Jesse experienced you know on a daily
basis during their their service hudner
passed away in 2017 but before his death
actor Glenn Powell promised him that his
story would make it to the big screen
it's wild to think back to that moment
when I met with Tom hudner and his
family and really got a very interesting
glimpse into how this relationship
really defined his life what do you
think Tom hudner and Jesse Brown would
say if they could see this movie I think
he'd say thank you in his final letter
to days he says I love you forever I
mean that's just epic to me and he was
only 24 years old and his love story is
still going I feel like our brother and
friend in Jesse Leroy Brown from
Mississippi from the mud to the sky it
would probably be saying thank you very
simply thank you for CBS mornings I'm
jerika Duncan
there is so much hope in that story I
love this is probably my favorite most
this is my favorite piece of the year
it's just so beautifully told and it
really not only puts you there but it
helps you understand this bond that
these two individuals had
um and when you hear uh Captain hudner
saying that he couldn't do anything
because he was pinned down and what it's
like to watch a man slowly slip off
I can't imagine but and the moral of all
this determination friendship between
men devotional devotion I cannot wait to
see it we'll be checking this out for
sure absolutely well devotion is out in
theaters now and you can hear more of
jarika's conversation with Glenn Powell
and Jonathan Majors on today's CBS
mornings podcast including how they met
and bonded at a Turkish Russian bath you
know listen to that too